[Music]  okay i don't think that was a man on  second thought i'm not i can't be too  sure as far as the idea that men  shouldn't chime in on abortion i i mean  just shut up shut the [ __ ] up  okay  let's run through the problems with that  claim one more time number one you can't  do that anymore  you believe that that there are no  differences between the male and female  bodies  it's fluid so you can't play this card  anymore that's been taken from you it's  gone it's not in the deck anymore you  can't play it also men decided roe v  wade so if we're going to get rid of  male opinions on abortion that means  we're getting rid of roe v wade men also  are 50 of the ingredients needed to  create an unborn child which you would  which you would also think would give us  a stake in the question i'm gonna have  an aneurysm if we watch too many more of  these